welcome desk IJ today we write answer
some questions that you guys have asked
me on Twitter and a few on YouTube I
hope that you're ready so sit down go
grab a cookie or some snacks and let's
do this questions here are the first one
I've already got an answer to but I'm
gonna read it to you anyway before I
answer the question because that's how
it works
then domain II a craft have you seen
Smosh Photoshop you and yes I have it
was kind of funny as I was watching them
Photoshop me I was like oh no don't go
to the booby so thank you guys very much
for enlarging my pistol region so thank
you thanks guys how many pets do I have
zero pets you know many animals because
I'm allergic I affirm ego Genet loves my
fart of you don't you hate it hates it
uh-huh here's one from Lindsay Lohan
lomond whatever I'm asking if I like
Lindsay lo but every time I pronounce
everyone yells because I do it wrong
Livan Lohan low on blowin I don't know
whatever Lindsay there isn't even like
her and truthfully I've never really met
her so I could not really judge her you
can't actually judge someone until you
actually meet them get to know them in
person it's like people tweet me all the
time I feel like I hate you I'm like oh
you don't even know me
all you know is this yelling ranging
YouTube then all you know about Lindsay
is a raging alcoholic and crazy driving
and drugs and stuff so maybe she's a
very nice person so that's my
long-winded answer
jess is asking how I'd like my Nike game
actually haven't tried it yet but I am
wearing my somewhere in the midst of my
and Michael Jackson looking jacket is
when I give you a bit more time say so
I'll keep you posted on how that it's
coming along that's clown is say oh sit
ask IG is trending look at that no I'm
gonna Jenna's looking it like I'm
looking at something why don't you look
at it I'm gonna put a little picture
right here would you rather only be able
to communicate by singing or be able to
dance to get from one place to another
I like to sing but I also like to dance
novels wants me to print one of my
sisters like do a strange phone call or
something no I'd already did that
Hellenic prank caller but I recalled my
sister at work to ask her about blood
sugar levels so I don't really want to
bother her because I felt bad she was
really busy Jenna wants to know if I can
live off of one food for the rest of my
life what would it be I would have to
say you would have to be candy here's
the right question from Scott if my
Furby went missing well would I replace
him or her with I wouldn't replace it I
don't think anything can replace that
annoying creature Carly wants to know
what I'm gonna do a grocery store vlog I
guess it hasn't been awhile since I've
done one of those I do need to go to the
grocery store today so perhaps today or
tomorrow Andrew is asking if I play in
fighting games I don't really consider
call of duty being a fighting game I
mean they're kind of fighting so really
that's as far as I get as far as
fighting shooting I mean other than
mortal combat that's really it
Alvin says you like being alone and do
you talk to yourself I actually do it's
funny bustling Far Cry 38 for a while
and I wasn't even recording the game but
I was literally talking to the screen as
if these people could hear me and
finally I realize oh they can't which
could be the coolest are you burning
something yeah I smell fire I smell fire
hopefully nothing's on fire okay good
in what part of America do you live it
and I live in Los Angeles it's part of
California yeah I smell fire something
burning are you sure nothing's burning
what's my favorite animal puppies do I
like pop yes I like pie these are a few
rapid-fire questions because are you
gonna do more youtubers react yes
definitely I absolutely love doing
youtubers react we haven't seen the past
two episodes that they shot check them
out and the fine for the channel because
it's so it's all funny hey guys I will
see you soon and be sure to leave them
some comments and tweet me some
questions so that I may answer them in a
future episode I will see you guys soon
be sure to subscribe check out the rest
of my YouTube channels and I'll see you
guys and another video
[Music]